Peggy 18
I guess it all started because no one
have made the game that we wanted to
play the game was really captured the
spirit of the original movie and a with
an alien there was terrifying massive to
make a game based not on action on horan
survival
this had to be a horror game we wanted
to create an experience that was
terrifying and claustrophobic a game
where you would spend the entire time
worrying about where the alien is
instead of the player cutting down
hundreds of aliens we have them focused
on a single creature and when you meet
it your first reaction should be to back
away and just find somewhere to hide
getting the story right was really
important to us we kept coming back to
the question when the Nostromo were
missing who would go searching for it
and that led us to Amanda Ripley and if
she went looking what would she find
in any isolation the player is a normal
person an extraordinary situation the
player isn't equipped with incredible
firepower or military hardware they are
isolated they are vulnerable and they're
just trying to survive moment with
whatever they can find an environment
that give them some kind of edge
we've taken the majority of our cues
from the original movie this kind of low
fly sci-fi has informed just about every
aspect of the arts from the architecture
to the character design the materials
were using visual effects lighting
everything comes back to this 1970s view
of the future
in the game all the technology has this
kind of mechanical push-button feel to
it
and that's really important to us
we really wants to take the series back
to its roots for the players are
confront the original alien
we really wants to make the alien game
that people have been waiting for